so today's topic Chris D'Elia so if you
aren't aware of Chris D'Elia is involved
in some sticky situations yes he's been
caught playing on the wrong playground
and essentially he's in trouble okay
he's a comedian and he's apparently been
involved with some young ladies we're
gonna separate this into two parts okay
so in this first video we're going to be
talking about power imbalances to age of
content 3 grooming okay so those are the
three things that we're gonna cover in
this video and then you guys can leave
you whatever kind of criticisms you want
other stances or ideas and then we'll
cover in a second video to kind of wrap
it all up okay I know pointing this
video are we endorsing Chris I'm not a
fan of his I have no interest me I'm
looking at this just purely from a
societal standpoint what does this mean
for men and women's relationship for
powerful men and young women what does
this mean for power dynamics and
relationships I want to kind of unpack
that more than anything
base all the conversations that I saw
most of the women that he was physically
involved with were between the ages of
18 and above and so that means it's
legal now there were a couple
conversations with girls were 17 maybe
one that was 16 but from what I was able
to see once they intimated or once they
said how old they were he would
generally retreat from what I've seen so
I'm gonna just talk about the women that
were legal based off what's allowed in
the United States so first off let's
discuss age of because a lot of people
hit me up and like adlets unacceptable
the age of consent is 18 11 first off
that's not true
age of consent is 18 in some states and
then it's 16 and others and in a lot of
Western countries they age of consent
legally speaking working 14 in Portugal
15 in France if you go down the list
you're gonna see that the age is way
lower so there is no consensus on this
from a legal standpoint so now let's
move on from the legality of it and
let's talk about the moral dilemma that
exists I say this as someone who who's
been through it in the sense that when I
was 17 I lost my knee to a woman who was
28 eleven years my senior and I've told
this story online a few times and
everyone's like man good job
lishus so already there's that
difference in the way that we perceive
each gender people are trying to make
the claim that because someone is 18
because someone is 1917 they don't have
the mental faculties to consent to this
and my question to you is that if
they're not ready for that why is it
that they're allowed to take out a
hundred thousand dollar loans for school
to join the military on a car drive down
the freeway at 90 miles per hour like a
proper adult but you tell me that they
don't have the mental faculties to make
this kind of decision that seems odd
I know 16 year-olds today who are being
charged as adults for murder for life oh
yeah yeah awesome so and to me it's
crazy because I'm like well where does
this line move is it because it's a
woman and a man involved that it's
inherently predatory like how are we
approaching this stuff and look I'm not
saying that his behaviors okay that's
not what I'm trying to say I'm saying
how do we determine what isn't moral
anymore right now because age of consent
and a consenting adult doesn't seem
clear we're saying these are strong
independent woman who can make these
decisions but at the same time they may
not have the emotional maturity enough
to make that decision well when do they
get that what age is it that their
responsibility because I know plenty of
women who are in their late twenties and
who are not emotionally haba the brain
doesn't fully develop until they're 25
ok so what should they only be allowed
and be able to consent at 25 is that
your argument man I know people with
mental disabilities who will never have
a fully developed prefrontal cortex can
they never consent if you take away
anything from this is this I need you to
understand that it's not a line it's not
a straight line
it's a giant squiggly line it's an area
where you don't is if the loft it's a
lot I'm I am I in the kitchen
am I in the living room and mind I don't
know it's the open space everything yeah
I don't know exactly where there is no
mind there is no so it's gonna depend on
now you're in the kitchen but you you
listen to you you listen to your
programs there that's the living room
perhaps the kitchen now right I feel as
the kitchen is the kitchen you know I
mean is that there's not even the line
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you that
you're not going to be more likely to be
more emotional mature until you're older
age but my thing is this if
not taking some kind of emotional
maturity test how is anyone to know your
level before you engage in a
relationship and if the barometer is
there not emotionally mature enough to
make this decision well what is it for
women who are much older and we're still
not a mostly Witcher is it predatory
then I don't have answers for this I
just have a lot of questions about that
you have a lot of information yeah it's
like even if you take your test because
you mentioned you mentioned the test
right right even if you take an
emotional test like a test to calibrate
well it doesn't mean anything because
some people perform well in the test
some people don't perform so even if you
put a test like yeah I don't I don't
have the answers either I don't know
there's some women who are 18 who mature
much faster and there's others who don't
right I don't know what to tell you but
it seems strange to me that there's like
such a flexibility for men to do as they
please in this regards and you see these
kind of stories like of young men with
older women whether it's Madonna
whether it's Kourtney Kourtney
Kardashian you know whether it's Madonna
JLo my mom yeah here's a thing we
acknowledge that men are responsible for
their actions soon as they're 18 despite
the fact that we feel like women are
socialized to be mature much faster so
we women are maturing much faster but
they're not able to handle those
decisions men mature less fast but they
can do whatever they want does that make
sense I've seen 14 years old means far
as I as a dolt 14 year old yeah so so so
it's just my confusion and to be clear I
have no propensity towards young one I
find it pretty gross for myself this is
my personal taste that being said I'm
not gonna use my barometer for what's
okay for me to determine whether other
people are immoral or not just because I
normally date older women it doesn't
mean that I'm expecting everyone else to
engage in that behavior if you guys are
enjoying today's video be sure to like
and comment it helps us out with
algorithm and pushing this channel other
people so please support that well hit
the bell none of it is clear so what a
35 year old man can't go for it 18 to 21
year old what if at 18 to 20 world
really wants to go further because I
know a lot of women personally family
members included who had 15 year age
gaps with the people that they were
dating and had zero problem with it let
me plenty
they seek these am i the want to tell
them you can't consent you were
you couldn't convey it's hard to tell
even though it's not my cup of tea no
I've never want that for myself it's
hard for me to look at other people that
you can why I can't logically think of
why next point is power imbalance
alright so I had actually of someone
responded me in this person Twitter
responder said it's all about power
dynamic
what's predatory here is that he
deliberately sought out underage or
barely legal fans not only quite mature
enough to fend off creepy advances but
also teen girls that I have a culture of
idolizing and crushing on stars which is
very cultivated by media and pop culture
makes them very reliable consumers but
also making some great victims for an
idol that turns predatory does he seek
out women around the ages of 17 to 22
yeah but we also have to have a
conversation about the fact that most
men in society prefer women around that
age
that's a weird conversation to have in
terms of ability and attractiveness to a
lot of men that age is the prime age
this is not my opinion these are backed
by statistics when you look at online
dating and what men like to swipe on
it's women around that age the average I
think was 21 there's like this funny
graph where you have the age of the man
right on one side and then the age of
the women they desire on one side so the
funny thing with this graph was that
even even as the age of the man rose the
age of the woman pretty much stayed the
same so it was just a straight line
whereas with women you would see a more
balanced line with like little dots here
they would normally men around their age
or above but for men it's different now
is that desired predatory is that kind
of age you got bad in a dating partner
or someone you want I don't think it is
even though it's not what I want I
science says that giant age gaps though
those relationships are very much
stigmatized they report higher levels of
happiness that's weird right ten plus
your age difference higher rates of
happiness within those relationships so
am I supposed to sit here and be like
y'all can't do this because I think it's
weird if they're consenting adults
what's the issue
how am I to determine that this person
is in cape
of consenting and let's say in hindsight
they felt like they weren't how is he
supposed to know that someone who said
yes was it able to actually say yes
now I will grant you that meant me to do
a better job of recognizing the
environment that women are raised in and
socialized in and make more of an effort
to really understand what that means for
them and I always give you this example
but like I've been in the bed with women
who you know let's say we're doing it in
a position and I think it's going well I
might note it's them winch and I'm like
hey is this ok this is painful you for
you and they'll say no and then I'll
keep going and I'll notice and once
again I'm like hey are you sure it's
painful say actually it is I'm like why
weren't you comfortable telling me that
and she says I don't know but what dawns
on me is that a lot of people are
incapable of asserting themselves what
I'm just laughing that's true
yeah laughing at you or what yes there's
a lot of yeah there's a lot of people
that are not able to do that and it
doesn't matter what position what age
they are or whatever would right they're
not able that and and and I can
understand that and I respect that but
my problem is it's not because men don't
go that extra mile that they're
inherently predatory the same way it's
not because Chris didn't ask those extra
questions and make that concerted effort
to make sure that these young women were
comfortable that he's inherently a bad
person and here's why I think Chris may
like maybe the biggest mistake is that
because we live in a society that we
live in and that we are more or less
part of communities I think well I think
what he did was bad was because he was
being very selfish hmm in that he wasn't
making a concerted effort to take into
consideration the other person's
potential vulnerability and they're
thirsty
he didn't make that concerted effort
from what we have right now aren't most
people selfish on they date I would
agree I would agree but I just don't
think that all dating has to be selfish
oh okay if you have you meet somebody
and they're in a vulnerable state
because they just came out of a
relationship you shouldn't be looking at
that situation period
from the stand point like what can I get
out of this you should also consider
what are the ramifications of the fact
that I'm gonna get involved with this
person when they're in such a tender
place how do you transfer that you link
what you just said to what he did
meaning what did he do that was selfish
well he didn't considering that they're
young and they may not be able to voice
their own agency make that extra effort
I'm not saying you have to but make that
extra effort to be like hey is this good
for you are you cool with this and in
doing so you're gonna save yourself a
lot of heartache because I can assure
you a lot of people agree the stuff that
they're not ready to do just because
they want adulation or love now this
doesn't make it evil this doesn't make
it bad but it does make it selfish and
both because if you're going to engage
in any kind of intimate behavior with
somebody you should have the minimum
amount of consideration to think about
their needs and their wants the same way
if you're gonna sleep with someone your
own physical pleasure should not be the
only thing you care about their pleasure
oh [ __ ] matter - so it's just about
thinking ahead do you think that doesn't
mean that you should acknowledge your
privilege power I mean kinda I think
it's a cringy way to say it yes yes I
wouldn't say that is the power of
expertise right don't you it's a crazy
way to say it but you having certain
power whether your power is knowledge
whether your power is Fame whether your
power is money whether your power is
actually a position of power you can do
come it comes with some privilege and
you have to you have to be able to
privilege such a bad word this is
subject to it nobody wants to hear that
word I know but it comes with part
Vantage's sharks there's so many other
words privilege you have power and
privilege or get the [ __ ] out of here
man I already hear it I understand that
but it comes with certain person's stuff
like that just be aware of those perks
be aware of what the position you're in
you know I mean it just comes to a
matter of empathy okay that's all it is
yeah you know I mean just think about
the other person as you engage in these
things yeah you know like I said any
other podcast like dating responsibly it
matters it matters you're gonna have a
much better love
if you're gonna avoid a whole bunch of
drama and you're gonna avoid hurting
people along the way
and I think that's what we all ideally
wanted to cuz he was just thinking about
his needs so he's just like hey what's
up okay are you in town great come over
my place right like that's all he was
thinking about
that's very primal yeah you know and not
evil not not necess
what it is selfish and I think when I
think of society and the kind of values
that I would like to propagate
themselves I do is that we're
considerate of other people that's it
majority of relationships are founded on
a power imbalance and this is self
report this is not my idea there studies
that confirm this we seek these things
out we seek them out all the time right
women prefer men who are taller than
them stronger bigger women or men world
their age or older this is not my
opinion these are statistics we build
these hierarchies right there's reason
why like there's a phenomenon called
dating up I don't want to date down I
want to date up what does that mean she
wants there to be that power imbalance
she wants someone with more power than
her that's also reality to acknowledge
some gender norms are things that we buy
into ourselves am I going to chastise
another man for playing the role that
society has encouraged men and women to
play for ever understand that this has
been in society ingrained in us for so
long is it inherently bad now I will
concede this that this power imbalance
more often than not
please against women doesn't mean it
always is bad thing but when it is it's
predominately women who are negatively
impacted and I understand that but it's
also important to know what role to all
of us play in encouraging these norms
and the second thing that I'm going to
say I don't see anything wrong with
using your fame as a means to get women
women use their accept you women use
their looks men use sometimes people use
their money I know women who use their
money to get mates I know men who use
their finances to get me if you want to
use your fame your social status what is
the problem what is the problem with
leveraging what you have in order to
garner affection and interest for
someone else from what I know he didn't
say hey do this for me or us I'll deny
you opportunities everywhere no he just
said yo hey
it's Chris what's up he was talking in
like he was a teenager I didn't see
anything inherently predatory about a
man who knows he has status approaching
a woman that's what I think about power
like when I was I was in college and it
was uh you know you have to choose what
program you want to go to and I would
actually be for college there are some
things that I just barred like I was
talking to my sister and I was like we
had this brief conversations like okay
well you know you always babysit kids
you could go and neck in the guard like
you know being someone someone that has
a kindergarten or be like I cross that
real quick man
a woman that takes care of kids aw she's
just you know being woman catering to
kids and caring men that take care of
kids is always seem creepy always looks
very creepy always looks very sus you
notice that what I'm saying the thing
that I wanted to say about the power is
is this it is not because there is an
imbalance of power they don't have the
same power that automatically there is
no consent it's not because let's say
for example I would decide to work at a
place and engage with my boss which is a
woman that she actually has power and
she tricked me
and it's not because she has that power
or if I'm a boss and there's a worker
and I engage in that I wouldn't but I
would yes I would engage in that that
she has no say in what happened that I
automatically tricked her into that
relationship it's not because there is
not the same power that I'm
automatically gonna use it to get you
some time it's just vibes you could be a
superstar she could be a normal person
and in vibes it doesn't mean that well
he used is use his stardom to get that
girl and that's super creepy it might
happen but it's not necessarily the case
it's not because the boss goes I was one
of his employees that easy like well if
you want to move up in the company
know what to do if also there's
something else to acknowledge go ahead
I dated quite a bit before I did
anything you too so now that I do this
and we're at the level that we're at
there's a lot of random people be
sliding in because they recognize that
sense of status I don't like to play on
it that's why predominantly hate the
idea of dating a fan or being involved
with them because I recognize how its
viewed societally mmm but yo I have
young women sixteen fifteen fourteen
seventeen hitting me up and being like
would you like some pictures I'm like
don't send me [ __ ] I'm dead-ass serious
I tell the people if you probably knock
you don't don't
and I tell these young great but I'm
being serious I don't want to have these
extended conversations with these people
I don't you gotta be extra careful man
brother yeah some people are bugging
into the eggs they are and what
responsibility do they bear for trying
to engage in that dynamic none none
because they're in that position where
they don't have power obviously he was
grooming I'm not saying he was not being
creepy
yeah and talking to these kids don't paw
my kids but I'm not saying they were 17
18 year old adults and older I ain't mad
at that the only one kid I ain't mad at
that and also another no another no
please stop calling him a pedo or a
father he's not okay if they're not
prepubescent that doesn't apply to that
definition okay let me address yes use
the words let your purse pederasty let's
just use the proper words yeah sizeable
difference III agree I agree I agree but
I'm not saying one thing the other I'm
just saying thank you yeah is it's it's
it's weird and it's weird and I think
that's why it's making me uncomfortable
cuz I recognize the weirdness and I have
to walk that line all the time I'm
telling you those people were mad
irresponsible my messages I'm like what
are you doing she's like yeah but I
think you're cute I don't care do you
understand like the age difference is
I'm here and then the last point is the
grooming point okay what is the
definition of grooming it's the idea of
using your influence or your power over
people who are substantially younger or
who have less power than you as it means
to cultivate them from to do what you
want once there
hmm and in then a lot of those cases I
don't think that what it was no you
can't qualify this their grooming is not
is that it's not that that's how it is
and I'm feeling that that word because
it was using a lot of documentaries that
came out well now I'm gonna talk about
them it's irrelevant but I think that
word was used a lot and people working
well I mean because of what happened
they had time to binge watch some of
them so they may be heard that turn a
lot and now they're using it but it's
like they don't apply it at the
Providence grooming
it's not that's not grooming hmm sending
you what text is not gloomy he's not
grooming you why not
because he's not building a relationship
like hey what's up I'm gonna pay for
this I'm your buddy you know you can you
can you can look you can count on me
that's not that's not it doesn't fall on
that if rooming is bigger and that's a
bigger scale than that saying what's up
to you and your DMS even if you're 16 is
not grooming you can call it creepy if
you want but it's not that that's not
what it is that's not the definition of
it creepy concur grooming not so much
but I think the last conversation that
we have to have is also the idea that
when it comes to dating none of us have
a manual we don't know how to do it
ethically we don't know how to do it
right compassionately most of us grew up
in divorced households most of us grow
up in dysfunctional relationships and
we're never taught even if you grew up
with even if you grew up not in the
divorce environment at home it doesn't
mean it you're not [ __ ] up it doesn't
mean that your parents are not [ __ ]
up it doesn't mean that it's not because
your parents are together that they're
not toxic so even if they're whether
they're separated or together they can
still you can still mess up it's you
know we've even been as weird if you
feel you can still have that example
yeah and you won't know which is which
until you try and you're told no that's
not right yeah so even then yeah yeah
but just also if you don't even have a
blueprint it's like what are you going
off of nor most of us don't know what
we're doing and so we're messing up and
and we're trying to figure it out and
we're hurting people that we love or
that we care about along the way because
we don't know
or doing we don't we don't and that's a
frightening thing to have to admit
because as men you know we're expected
to take the lead to be ethical to know
exactly how to do it but at the same
time it's like who's here to guide us
maybe in your Twitter sphere you guys
are having these conversations and it's
clear but for a lot of people who don't
live in that bubble and we're always
around it we don't know we don't and
when I just see Chris D'Elia being
chastised online and rightfully so in a
lot of cases it doesn't provide me with
a lot of clarity on who how to do this
and how to do it ethically and so that's
why you see men taking extreme stances
oh I there's a power imbalance and I
can't interact with a woman alone well
then that's gonna make herself right
working for it's like people are taking
extreme reactions to this because they
don't know how to do they don't know how
to walk that fine well that's how you
that's how you protect yourself
sometimes is too much but sometimes
there's a reason for that
there's a reason like you feel unsafe
you know yeah maybe walking with pepper
spray in your purse is a bit much but
there's a reason for that
I can't tell you that you're wrong I can
understand why you have that there why
you have a weapon in there you know I
can understand where it's from but it's
a reaction to something else yeah so and
that's for a lot of thing that's
everybody that's just not woman that's
not just women that's man as what man
see you know and we don't know we can't
know we can we don't we don't know how
it works it's just like comedy comedy
unfortunately you learn how to do comedy
when you [ __ ] up
when you mess up I mean I bomb it hurts
I learn I get back up I go back onstage
and I learned to be funny yeah if if
that's how you're able to advance in
life so I guess that's pretty much it
one hear your thoughts leave your
comments below
[Music]
well started with the well it's funny
how he is playing a character that is
exactly who he is in real life yeah cuz
he played a character in the TV show you
and he basically played a guy who preyed
on a young woman to be fair to me I
don't really see the relevance because
yes there was a young woman in Falls but
in you he them I liked the boy and he's
like while they're asleep that's when he
goes at it okay
based off of some stuff that he gave
them this is not that this is the idea
that he talks to young women and that
waits for them to get a little bit older
but anyways but this is my thing right
like this is also I say as a grown man
don't talk to women no no as a grown man
don't talk to kids no topic is any
interaction that you're gonna have is
gonna be perceived as personal you
remember when you remember when we were
doing that life yeah and that's 16 year
old came on yeah anyone would like
another boy 15 you know when like when I
kiss many don't you wanna talk about
this issue with yeah so because I know
this avoid kids people leaving your mind
at the party and I know some of you be
like that's being ridiculous I'm really
not like if I can just and a lot of men
are gonna understand what I'm talking
this winter
we had a we had a Christmas party over
the family of my girlfriend all right
and it was two kids there and they were
playing they were playing us and I felt
I felt really tired at some point like
I'm gonna take a nap and I wanted to go
downstairs but the two kids were playing
downstairs I'm like no a little boy and
a little girl like I'm not gonna go I'm
not you're not gonna catch me slippin
seeing these cheats right you know
because I don't know I don't know these
kids I don't know like yesterday but I
don't know what they have in mind what
they're gonna say how they're gonna you
know I don't I don't know I don't know
yeah and if they say something that
didn't happen I'm losing weight yes I've
seen that happen so